here's how i would present difficult
news to my spouse if i wasn't sure how
they were going to take it i would first
go back to the three things that
everyone has to be aligned on we have to
be aligned on where we're going how
we're going to get there and our
interests along the way i would relate
this because if it's a big decision it's
going to be a mission related decision
this is like what we're going to do with
our lives the values pieces i'm saying i
want to get there a different way than i
currently am so i might be quitting my
job i might be starting a new business
it might be whatever it is but i have to
then align these are the things that
we've already agreed on my belief is
that me switching this vehicle is
actually more in alignment with these
values the reason that you should be
making the switch is because you think
that the change you're making is more
aligned with the mission and more
aligned with the values now it's up to
them to say why they don't agree with
that you can still have at least
agreement on the fundamentals of
discussion that you're going to have
with them if you are playing by the same
rules it makes it a much more productive
conversation which then goes back to the
original thing which is you need to be
aligned on mission you need to be
aligned on values and you blind on
similar interests and if you are it
makes everything else easier